I think that people don't really know
what suman's sex-trafficking is I think
it's sort of an odd myths that people
think exists but doesn't exist and the
film is basically something that we try
to capture visually to sort of show how
much people don't understand seeing an
eight-year-old girl being raped by a man
an adult man and then being prostituted
that is not the kind of business anyone
should be in and I think one of the
things that people are just beginning to
wake up to in this country at least I
hope is that this isn't just actually a
problem abroad there's actually human
trafficking here in the u.s. that's
right it's not just a global issue
outside of the United States and the
United States is completely impenetrable
this is something that is happening in
the United States 700,000 children and
women and young girls being trafficked
in the United States and I think if you
look at what's happening currently in in
the news this whole immigration issue is
also a problem too because these
children are going to be without their
families and that is something that is
going to make them vulnerable and what
is it that you want people to take away
from the film how can they go for
watching we want this film to be
something that is accessible so that
people can watch it without paying for
it they can link on it's only 20 minutes
long we have it available on the
Internet if they go on meena the movie
com they can watch it and I think it
took four years for this movie to be
seen because a lot of people were afraid
the content was too intense and too
violent and too disturbing and you know
what it probably is but if you don't
watch it and you don't involve yourself
in it you're never really going to
understand what is going on outside of
your own home